miss presidential scana Darton norbert
Hoover you're looking at the friendly
face of far-right politics a
well-tailored Austrian called Norbit
Hoffer who sells anti-immigrant policies
with a smile
he certainly struck a chord with an
increasingly polarized electorate after
the warm-up act mr. Hoffer told a packed
whole in Vienna the time had come to put
ordinary Austrians first dish that I
hearing on the hysterical Austrian men
and women have a strong will to succeed
to make this country a success the old
dust has to be shaken off and then we
will be proud to be Austrian again his
campaign for president is calculated and
effective exploiting fears of mass
immigration it would be better he says
if they simply stayed at home is a
mentioning of a pet leashed hissic for
new these people aren't working [ __ ] so
I say give these asylum seekers the
skills so they can rebuild in their own
countries now that would be a meaningful
task he's in a really tight race with
his Green Party opponent but hopper is
writing the anti-establishment way at a
worldwide phenomenon that and it's
clearly energized his party
and post brexit there are many in
brussels and beyond who are worried
about Norbit hotter mr. hopper should
Europe beer you know no ice now because
i'm afraid the normal but guy i have to
say i'm not far right this the second
time mr. Hoffer and his rival from the
green party aleksandr van de belem have
fought for the presidency an earlier
poll won by van de belem was cancelled
after voting irregularities and it is
immigration that has dominated the
national debate here a group of
self-described all right activists hang
a veil on the statue of a former empress
a protest at the mass islamization of
austria they say last year it accepted
90,000 asylum seekers you look pretty
hit but I think a lot of people would
say that what you're doing is basically
research I think that's a huge problem
for society that all the people
especially my young generation only had
the alternative between multiculturalism
and noon at ism and every right-wing
politician is criticizing immigration is
literally hitler and we are fed up with
this we are no racist we are no
anti-semitic on units we just want to
preserve our own ethnic cultural
identity mr. van de belem also made his
final plea an economics professor he is
the establishment and the celebrities
choice two good reasons then to fear the
result this is how stop to it you don't
need to demolish the house just because
a couple of Windows have become loose
even if the roof has started to leak the
foundations are solid we won't solve
these problems with radicalism more
extremism only with reason may appeal to
at the Christmas market we found
Austrians battling the political chill
many here in cosmopolitan Vienna worry
about a far-right president many
countries have the right left problem
right now and we're one of them so yeah
I think it's going to be a really
interesting Sunday for all of us their
country stands at the crossroads and
where Austria goes others may follow
john sparks Sky News in Vienna